playing spec Ops the Line was truly an
experience number before has a game
connected me to its main protagonist
this well while also telling me how much
of a bad person I am for doing so spec
Ops the Line is not a happy game it's
one that will attempt to tear you apart
and will succeed in doing so so long as
you keep playing and today I want to
take some time to talk about my
experience with this game so without
further Ado let's get started
I honestly cannot do better than the
game itself when it comes to describing
what spec Ops the Line is all about
before you start the game you can
already tell something is wrong as the
main menu shows an upside down American
flag flying over a recently destroyed
Dubai while the American national anthem
is playing over a loudspeaker across the
country it's also Out Of Tune at some
points it even stops mid-song which
connects the utter destruction right in
front of us this is already a good start
but you could go even further back than
this the Xbox game store has screenshots
from the game you're currently looking
at to help you get an idea as to what
you're getting into and while games like
Call of Duty and Battlefield show
bombastic action with explosions big
guns and vehicles spec ops shows this
if that doesn't immediately convey the
kind of tone we're going for here I
don't know what will I'll be mentioning
those other games at a few more Shooters
throughout this video quite a bit as
it's key to understanding this game
because spec Ops the Line is a typical
shooter game which is a problem as it
had to go up against some of the
behemoths of the genre around this time
but where those games tend to focus on
big explosions and heroic stories spec
ops wanted to stand out for the rest and
it all starts in Dubai in the world of
spec ops Dubai was hit by a massive
Sandstone that practically destroyed the
entire city foreign Ada rescue teams
were sent in to investigate and assist
any who needed it one person was Colonel
Conrad and his Battalion the damn 33rd
everything seemed okay all things
considered until the stress call came
back from Conrad himself saying that the
evacuation was a failure and that they
need help this is where we come in Delta
Force Under the command of Captain
Walker our protagonist along with his
Squad mates Lugo and Adams were sent
into Dubai to assess the situation and
radio for evacuation one thing I noticed
right away is how well the game
characterizes our Squad mates Walker is
the very boring and generic Commander
which is completely fine as he's being
controlled by us Adams is your standard
military man who takes things very
seriously and Lugo is the comedic relief
right he's right
hey command wants us to look around we
look around I don't know sounds like a
waste of three stone cold ruggedly
handsome Delta operators such as
ourselves
think of it as a paid vacation well for
future reference I prefer my beaches
with a three to one sexy lady dead body
ratio Lugo do you ever actually hear the
[__] coming out of your mouth no I do
not sir I find it messes with my rhythm
being comedic relief can have the
downside of being the character's only
personality a great example I tend to
point to when it comes to Comedy done
well is Cole and Baird from Gears of War
the majority of their dialogue is
wisecracks and jokes but they take
things seriously when they need to and
they also have moments where they come
to terms with certain problems in their
life this creates a healthy balance of
both and I think Lugo Nails this really
well he and Adams are kind of like the
angel and devil that sits upon Walker's
shoulders Lugo tends to want to save
people and is vehemently against mortar
striking a squad later due to the weapon
they are using whereas Adams is
comfortable with said weapon that being
said they don't stay this way for very
long as both end up crossing over to
each other's sides which shows just how
much this Mission changed everyone as
they approach a broken down Convoy the
team finds one of the 33rd soldiers
along with a few locals Who Am push them
apparently these guys are the survivors
of the storm which is a good thing as
these are the people we're trying to
find but obviously they're attacking us
which is not a good thing in all
fairness though we are three soldiers
onto the teeth so we do come off as a
bit of a threat that being said Walker
and the team don't attempt to radio this
in and said push further into the City
and attempt to find out what's going on
along the way the player will get
introduced to the gameplay and it's
honestly quite difficult to discuss
because it's exactly what it looks like
spec Ops the Line is your
run-of-the-mill third person cover based
shooter this game like others of its
kind do try to add some unique elements
to the Gunplay like shooting glass
ceilings and windows to drop sand on
people but outside of that if you've
played a game like this in an in-depth
description of its mechanics isn't
necessary this whole system is a
strangely shaped double-edged sword
though spec Ops the Line was going
against some real Heavy Hitters in the
industry not just the big names like
Call of Duty or Battlefield but these
specific games within those franchises
just a year before this game Battlefield
3 was released Black Ops 2 is released
the same year as spec ops in games like
Halo 4 and Gears 3 also surrounded it
now while only one of those is a
cover-based shooter all the these games
have much better mechanics than spec ops
does this same sentiment is actually how
I feel about most of the mechanics or
systems in this game as the sum of Parts
it's okay but other games do each thing
better this became an issue on release
as spec ops wasn't exactly reshaping the
mold in any way as they preferred to
just play it safe but this is where that
other Edge comes in because nowadays
people are likely to not buy this game
for the gameplay given how many games do
it better so it ends up being the story
that people are here for I want to
clarify I don't find the gameplay to be
bad like I said it's a very basic cover
shooter and I have no problem with the
genre I'm just describing this to you as
it's the same thing we discussed when
talking about Metal Gear survive but the
other way around that game had a real
lack of story for most of the game so
the gameplay was a thing that needed to
keep people interested but to me it
wasn't able to spec Ops the Line is
likely not going to win people over with
the gameplay so it's on the story to do
so which works given that that seemed to
be the entire point the team behind the
game called the Jaeger development
really put all their eggs in one basket
here as the part of the game that seems
to have gotten the most care in
consideration was the story as the rest
feels thrown together because they
needed to but thankfully it worked as
the story is the strongest aspect by far
as the Drew continues to the wreckage of
Dubai they'll find another 33rd member
trapped in a plane as we're carefully
executing the insurgents he'll tell the
group that one of their men was taken to
a place called The Nest while they walk
the team naturally discusses what to do
next which is what leads Walker to say
that their mission has went from Recon
to rescue very quickly and that they
need to get the U.S soldiers out of here
remember this for later this section of
the game is where I start to get a
little nervous though while we fight
some more militia members rock music is
playing in the background and while it
added to the fight it sometimes felt
more horrific than it was supposed to be
as this isn't a one-time thing as most
of the battle music in the game is
actually played through a speaker by a
DJ here which is an interesting way of
canonizing battle music in games but
still the music would sometimes play out
very softly in these rundown areas with
hundreds of bodies in it and it kind of
gives off this Eerie feeling like
something's not right here which
Speaking of that Jaeger did a really
good job of conveying the eeriness
throughout most of the game some of it's
a bit more obvious at times but things
like spray paint saying things like God
help us or please grant us Mercy or just
the overall architecture of the place
really does a good job at establish how
run down and destroyed this version of
Dubai is
after battling through waves of locals
and falling into a sand pit we find an
american guy working for them at the
time it was safe to assume that the
Dubai locals were revolting against the
American soldiers that were stationed
here to help them and while that's still
a fair assumption to have right now it's
clear that something else is going on
underneath the surface thanks to this
guy around this time is also where
Walker will find a doll this is a
collectible piece of Intel in the game
and while they won't go through every
piece of Intel I do want to highlight
this one specifically according to
Walker the materials it's made out of
points of this being made after the dust
storm meaning that there are people who
are still here that aren't just the
local militia this weighs on Walker
quite heavily as he starts to question
if the people he was supposed to save
are the people he's currently killing he
ends up rationalizing this by saying
that anyone who shoots at him is his
enemy regardless of if their families or
not
something quite consistent about Walker
is his ability to rationalize his
horrific decisions some of which are
impossible to no matter what way you
look at them it's actually quite
impressive though is usually this kind
of thing would create a disconnect
between the player and the player
character but I found myself agreeing
with Walker's decisions well most of
them anyway because he and I both
recognize that while things are starting
to get bad it's all going to end well
once we take control as we have a good
heart and want to help people yeah we're
killing a lot of people but the killing
will stop once we reach our objective
and radio command for evacuation this
section of the game is where a part of
that mindset started to develop as the
trio finally catches up to that American
guy we found earlier who was immediately
killed thanks to us distracting him the
guy who killed him is conveniently the
person we were supposed to find who
tells us that he's with the 33rd and
that the man we just saw die in front of
us was from the CIA more specifically
acia task force called gray fox
God damn it a few more Intel pieces we
can pick up before this point to certain
events of this tragedy being covered up
a reporter was sent here by a new
station to cover the tragedy but the
teleprompter told her that an evacuation
force was coming to rescue them despite
the fact that this was something she had
not heard of before this album confirms
that someone has an ulterior motive here
and is trying to do something here in
Dubai this guy though is reluctant to
help us and actually send some of his
men to kill us or once again the 33rd
the people we're trying to find here is
where me and Walker started to
rationalize things because now we're
killing the people we're trying to
rescue originally I agreed with Walker
and said that while this is definitely
not how things should be going we're
almost done here and it was only a
couple of on edge soldiers who have to
fight for their lives since they arrived
I started to retract that statement an
hour or so later though when I realized
I was still fighting the 33rd Battalion
in fact I don't think you ever fight
another local Insurgent member again I'm
fairly certain every single enemy from
this point forward is a member of the
33rd this is where the game started to
confuse me as I couldn't figure all what
was going on here we just went from
helping the locals to killing the locals
to helping the 33rd to now killing them
it's bizarre and made me confused as to
what the hell we were even doing anymore
which was completely intentional as
you're supposed to be confused the game
is purposely trying to toy with you and
make you question what you're even doing
here to Circle back to the interaction
with the soldier though this is one of
our first choices in the game even
though it doesn't mean much oddly enough
I was going to wait to discuss the
choices until a bit later when we get to
the hanging part but I found out later
on a different playthrough that you
could just shoot this guy instead of
letting him walk away actually quite a
few of the choices in this game are like
this whether choices you may not have
known are actually a thing in this case
I didn't even know you had a choice I
thought him leaving was supposed to
happen but it's not and I have to admit
that's pretty damn cool for the next few
minutes we're going to be running
through various buildings and are forced
to take out more 33rd members along the
way and it's hero I want to highlight
two things one is the dialogue I played
a lot of Shooters in my time but I've
never heard dialogue like this before no
one ever shuts up in this game Delta
Force in the 33rd constantly communicate
with each other all the time and not
only does it feel incredibly realistic
but it's almost overwhelming at times
there is rarely a moment where things
just stop people are either screaming or
dying and guns never seem to stop firing
it's just a lot at once and it really
brings you into the action
reloading
up
[Applause]
watch it shotgun
nail him down
[Music]
anybody
it might be a bit hard to hear but I
find that that's what's so brilliant
about this is these guys are literally
screaming at the top of their lungs and
you can still barely hear them over the
constant gunfire it also makes the squad
feel more like a team rather than a
player into unimportant NPCs because a
lot of this dialogue is something you'll
hear throughout the game each of them
will call out knife and shotgun users
all the time and comments from them
about enemies pinning them down or how
one of them is rushing towards the team
is also something you'll hear in regular
combat throughout the game
I think it's a large reason why despite
its Simplicity I enjoyed the gameplay
because I was always mentally thrown
into the fight thanks to all the [__]
going on around me this constant state
of being on edge and making sure to stay
alert of enemies nearby end up creating
the second moment I want to highlight
and that's this section right here
while fighting the player is forced to
go down this hallway and flank the
machine guns while Lugo and Adams
distracted and among the soldiers is a
random civilian who walks into your line
of fire while there are some civilians
in this level most are either killed
before you get the chance to save them
or they're hiding far away from the
fight this is the one time a civilian
actually runs in front of you and it
honestly shocked me when I shot this
woman I was originally confused why the
reticle was green and was wondering if
all the soldiers were green too is a
sort of meta message that we're shooting
the good guys but no every Soldier shows
up red like normal and that's when I
realized that this was just some random
old lady I shot what's even more
surprising is that the game lets you
continue with this usually in games with
civilians you're either given a warning
or just straight up fill the mission if
you kill a civilian but spec ops lets
you continue I thought for a long time
as to why they let you do that not even
knowing that later one old woman would
be the least of my problems as we clear
out of the building the refugees who
originally made this place their home
want us to leave you might question why
and I did too we just saved them but
realistically we really didn't the 33rd
at the moment seemed to be the bad guys
but not only is that information spotty
at best we also destroyed the civilian's
home in the process of trying to save
them yeah the 33rd looked like they were
rounding up people and killing them
luckily because of an earlier scene
where we saw some of the soldiers
butchered and executed but still we
didn't exactly make their current
situation any better plus it's not even
taking into account the amount of people
that died while this battle happened a
common story beat in this game is Delta
Force coming into quote unquote save the
day only to make the situation worse
than it was when they got there and this
is one of those moments once they leave
they come across a signal from
Lieutenant Daniels the group then
decides to find him with the hope that
Conrad is nearby but they also recognize
that this was broadcasted on purpose
likely to lure out other CIA members and
it's around here where the game starts
to turn from an action hero movie to
something a bit more Sinister as right
under this pile of rubble is hundreds of
dead bodies there are so many bodies in
here it's hard to tell where one ends
and the other begins it's also hard to
tell if it's blood burn marks or both
plus we also have to ask why this is
even here according to Walker these guys
are part of the 33rd but the people who
own this building are also the 33rd
meaning the group turned on each other
and this was the result
hundreds of corpses are put together to
form a Dumping Ground while the rest are
tied up in chairs a nearby Intel file
will give us a bit more insight into
these specific methods of torture here
these men were waterboarded cut with
knives and even burned it seems like the
writer of the note was someone who went
through this torture and decided to
enact it on the same people who did it
to him a bit later but in his case it
seems like it wasn't for the purposes of
information it doesn't take hundreds of
people to get the information you need
so he likely did it as payback once
again this is all well and good but we
still don't know what the hell is going
on here it's bad enough that the 33rd
was being attacked by the CIA but now we
learned that they turned on each other
things start making even less sense
after this as the trio has been set up
by the 33rd which they expected but what
they didn't expect was that a CIA agent
named Gould is here to save them the
player like Delta Force is really just
going through the motions at this point
as no one has a solid grasp as to what's
going on and I would argue they never
really learned the real truth until the
very end of the game the one piece of
info we do learn is that the CIA seem to
have stirred things up here in Dubai
thanks to them arming the locals so we
have a group of American soldiers who
may or may not have killed a bunch of
people in fighting within the group
itself the locals who are taking up arms
against the 33rd to take over the city
and then there's the CIA who armed these
locals for some reason oh and yeah we
have some Jackass over the radio poking
fun at Delta Force the whole time
as a fresh wave of Americans make Dubai
their vacation destination of choice
when asked what he thought of these
fresh new faces a local Dubai man had
these words to say
to say the story is confusing is an
understatement but once again it's
supposed to be and the story will
eventually come back around to tie up
these Loose Ends so it's not like it's
going to keep you confused for very long
shortly following that lovely segment is
the 33rd attempt at preventing more
insurgencies as they've opted to kill
those that betrayed them and hang the
bodies as a warning wonderful right
behind this is another tunnel filled
with dead bodies that belong to the
insurgents so Gould and his CIA friends
use the locals as bait so they can get
in closer but and I don't even know how
this is even possible at this point it
gets even worse as the moment we come
out of the tunnel white phosphorus is
dropped onto the survivors I have a lot
to say about this particular weapon
later so we'll Circle back to this in a
moment after carefully walking around
the body Source did not catch fire
they'll come across Gould in a few
civilians who are being held captive one
of the soldiers uses a unique form of
torture that I've never seen before in
order to get gold to talk about the CIA
they take a woman and unload an entire
clip right next to her I was originally
confused as to what this would have
accomplished but I'm assuming the
bullets going into the sand would have
kicked it up in her face plus the
bullets are also red hot when firing out
of a gun so there's a good chance it's
burning her too plus there is of course
the more obvious point and that's that a
full mag of a gun being shot right next
to you is Extremely Loud and terrifying
to hear Gould doesn't talk though so the
soldier next to him just caps her right
after from here though we have two
choices save the civilians or save gold
oddly enough luga wants to save gold and
not the civilians which is something I'm
a bit puzzled about as he seems to be a
bit more of a caring individual than
Adams is but Lugo does make a good point
by saying that while it does suck Gould
is vital to our mission my initial
decision was to save the civilians as
ghoul to loyalty is questionable at best
but I screwed up and ended up doing the
other choice instead the game didn't
really give me a clear indication of
what option I was choosing so I figured
that this was the option I wanted I
realized later that I should have
followed Adams as going to the left
would have taken me to the civilians I
wanted to save regardless if you save
the civilians gold is dead if you save
Gould the civilians die a ton more guys
come out to fight and then gold dies
anyway both outcomes result in ghoul
dying which kind of sucks but it makes
sense as him not being alive to give
them info on a place called the gate is
going to cause some problems for them
very soon before we can get there though
some infighting within the group starts
to emerge the Dubai desert is really
affecting these three as all their
emotions and nerves have gone off the
rails and it's hard to blame them any
normal person would be in a state of
disarray after the stuff we've talked
about Walker attempts to calm the two
down but you can tell the two are going
to snap again the next time something
happens unfortunately that next time is
right now as we're about to enter
probably the most gut-wrenching scene in
the game right in front of the team is
an army of 33rd soldiers Adams
recommends using the mortar Cannon
nearby filled with white phosphorus Lugo
is completely against it and reminds
Walker that he knows what this thing
does to people and as the player we also
know this as we just saw it in action
just a few moments ago now I thought
this was another choice but the game
forces you to use this device as enemies
seem to lock onto you immediately the
moment you move out of cover so it's
impossible to take all of them out
without using the mortar so we have no
choice but to use the white phosphorus
and as expected it's very efficient now
what phosphorus may seem like a normal
explosive but you may not be aware of
the full extent of its destruction white
phosphorus is a chemical that can ignite
almost immediately when exposed to air
the problem comes when trying to
extinguish it as simply cutting off the
oxygen is only temporary as the moment
you remove the lid covering it it will
reignite again even if you douse it in
water it will eventually reignite once
the water evaporates furthermore this
thing releases a lot of fumes so anyone
caught in this thing will be inhaling
all that smoke completely ruining their
lungs and internal organs that's also
not even considering the more obvious
problem and that's the burns of being
hit by it as this thing goes as high as
a thousand degrees Fahrenheit
it is such a deadly weapon that has been
banned by the UN now it seems as though
as long as the chemical is used in less
lethal ways like smoke grenades it seems
to be fine but I've read conflicting
information that its bold outright band
or only okay to use against soldiers and
not civilians but it's also war and
rules kind of go out the window when
it's light for death to my surprise
though spec ops was not the first game I
played that had this as I forgot until
now that Call of Duty also used this in
Modern Warfare 2019 and while that
mission didn't put a major focus on the
weapon itself there was still an
underlying feeling of concern as the
weapon was more than successful at
destroying the base we were attacking
and if Call of Duty a game where most of
the action is focused on fun heroic
moments can still take the time to show
how destructive something like this is
how do you think spec ops handled this
stop talking
oh God
come on man there's nothing we can do
why
you brought this on yourself
we were helping
what
while this is bad enough as is the next
part is even worse I'm not sure how much
I'm allowed to show as this isn't very
ad friendly of me but around us is a
pile of burned corpses with the one that
sticks out from all the rest being a
mother holding her child in her arms
both of whom are dead if there was ever
a scene in this game that would stick
with the player the most it's this one
not only are we still killing American
soldiers but we also wiped out an entire
group of civilians in the process the
choice to use a mother and child was
smart as it's the most common thing
media will use when conveying something
disastrous and evil as it shows us that
the person responsible was willing to
kill a mother and child to get what they
wanted and walk her and by extension the
player did just that I also love the
small detail of having Walker's face
appear on the screen when you fire as
it's an attempt at showing who's really
behind the screen that of course being
us it also does a good job of showing
Walker's inability to admit what's right
in front of him and also his attempt to
deflect the blame onto someone as his
first instinct is to blame the 33rd as
they forced his hand Lugo mentioned
something like this earlier when he said
that there is always a joke voice but
Walker disagrees and said that this time
there wasn't this is where I started to
break away from Walker as my first
thought was exactly what Adam said I was
thinking Christ Walker we're not even
going to bring this up I originally
thought he was doing this so that he
could remain calm and level-headed as
the other two were clearly losing their
mind over what just occurred but then I
started to realize that it was because
Walker was using the 33rd as a scapegoat
in order to put the blame on someone
else which is definitely not the route I
expected him to go down this is also
where the game officially starts to
change in Tone If the past few minutes
weren't enough to convince you that the
game was going for something more
serious this time this surely would
what's through the cherry on top of all
of this is that once again we still have
no damn clue what we're even doing here
it's been three hours since we started
the game and we're halfway through it
and we still have no clue who's on whose
side and who the good guys are in all
this usually I would say this lack of
development is bad writing but it works
so well here in Spec Ops as it forced
you to look back on the things you do
understand which really hammers in those
events of the story I might not know if
the CIA or the 33rd are the bad guys but
I do know that I just bombed a group of
civilians and I don't really feel good
about it my only complaint with this
scene and it is incredibly minor is that
it was quite obvious that these were
civilians from the moment I saw them on
the tablet my first thought when seeing
them was oh these are definitely
refugees and the resulting explosion
going off right near them pretty much
convinced me that I'd killed a bunch of
Innocents from the way the scene is
designed it seemed like it was supposed
to be a huge plot twist but I noticed
right away the that being said it didn't
take away from the scene at all as I had
no idea the amount of Destruction that
would follow and the way the game forces
you to walk through here so as to say
look at this look at what you just did
was excellent
much to the team's confusion Walker
demands that they move on and continue
forward as they still have a job to do
Lugo continues to poke at Walker over
this decision but he sticks with the
fact that their hand was forced nearby
is another room of tortured soldiers is
confirmed by none other than Conrad
himself that they are some of the Rogue
33 members Walker believes that all of
this is Conrad's doing and that he isn't
as good as he thought he was so now we
finally have something to go off of
before we can digest that though we have
another choice in front of us are two
people each of whom have committed some
kind of crime and Conrad wants us to
choose the person we choose dies and the
other lives Conrad wants us to choose so
that we can understand the kind of thing
he has to go through every day he wants
us to make the hard decisions so what
are they while the man on the right
tried to steal water for his family he
was caught and the man on the left was
sent to bring him in but ended up
killing the other man's family in the
scuffle if you don't choose in his dead
stall for time Delta Force will be shot
and killed so the player must choose
personally I think the choice is quite
obvious but I am interested to hear the
other side of the argument between
stealing water and killing a family I
think the more dangerous crime is
obvious which is why I chose to let the
civilian live if we are to use the
game's logic here his hand was forced
the Dubai desert is very deadly and as
we'll soon see later the 33rd run the
water in this city so it's not just
something you could just go to the store
and buy you likely have to pass a few
inspections to be eligible for it and
even then there's a good chance you can
only take so much per person
so the man on the right was just trying
to feed his family the man on the left
was a marine he's a trained killer and
it's his duty to defuse situations like
this and make the correct decisions
however what we lack is context how much
water was it was it from the military or
another family's home did the family
attack the Marine leaving him no choice
but to put them down it's one of those
questions where it becomes harder to
choose the more you think about it so
for me I just look at what I know as
there's no point in going back and forth
on what ifs and hypotheticals if I'm
never going to get them anyway that's
why I ultimately ended up choosing the
civilian but if he chose the Marine I'd
love to hear why is maybe I missed
something
it's once again another good choice from
the game but I do have some questions
about this later as it doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense with the last
minute plot twist but like I said we'll
talk about that at the End by the way
right over this Sand Dune nearby is
another group of 33rd waiting for the
trio to pop their heads out as they
battle through the wreckage of Sandstorm
hits so they have to go find cover in a
large drain pipe they seem to stay here
for quite a while as it becomes night
when they exit a little further down the
road is where the team meets Riggs and
other CIA agent he's working with the
locals to take over a nearby water
facility as taking it down would [__]
the 33rds hold over the area so while
the refugees go ahead and attract the
33rd we and rigs are going to go through
the back and take them out Conrad
objects to our decision to help Riggs as
he claims he's going to bury the truth
which ends up actually being correct as
stewing the water from the 33rd not only
cripples them but all of Dubai meaning
all the people left in the city are
likely going to die in a few days thanks
to the last remaining supplies of water
being destroyed the reason Riggs did
this was because the CIA wants to cover
up what happened here see when the
sandstorm hit the city was in disarray
and that's when the US Army sent in
Conrad and the 33rd to evacuate the
civilians this ended in a complete
failure though as he ended up getting
over 1300 people killed in the process
that radio transmission we hear in the
beginning regarding the evacuation being
a failure was this incident and the
broken down cars and dead bodies belong
to the people from this incident since
Dubai was essentially shut off from the
rest of the world no one knew what
happened or what was going on so the CIA
decided to cover up the incident by
basically killing everyone left in the
city as if the Middle East found out
what Conrad did they would start a war
with America and the government knows
that it's a war they can't win
thanks to our ignorance though Riggs got
exactly what he wanted and now Dubai has
days before it's completely gone the
townsfolk are less than happy with us as
one of them berates us while the rest of
them filled their jokes with whatever
water is left Riggs accidentally got
caught in the blast and is stuck under
the truck which leads to our next choice
letting him die in the fire or mercy
killing him with a bullet I chose to let
him burn not just for deceiving us but
for thinking that killing all of Dubai
is the right choice here
as if we needed more problems on our
plate Delta Force has been split up
again so we have to regroup Lugo and
Adams and jackass returns once again to
really emphasize how badly we screwed up
after a long fire fight the team were
groups and also manages to find a
surrendered Soldier he'll give us the
location of the radio man allowing us to
finally take him down he didn't get a
chance to finish but apparently his
badge number was
867-5309 which is a funny reference this
leads into another long combat encounter
and is probably the longest the game
goes on any sort of story progression as
we're going floor by floor in order to
reach the top but during this you'll
start to notice that Walker is changing
not just physically but mentally he
kicks one of the soldiers when riding
down a zip line but the guy looks
exactly like our Squad mate Adams this
same thing will happen a bit later but
with a heavy gunner that's dressed like
Lugo Walker's mind has been Conjuring up
hallucinations in fact it's been
happening since the start of the game as
this giant building has a poster of
Conrad on it but one of the loading
screens in a later Mission shows that
it's actually just a woman furthermore
although I could be wrong but this truck
right after the water explodes also
seems to have an image of Conrad on it
but this doesn't just extend to the
hallucinations but the actual combat as
well as I said earlier the team likes to
communicate orders constantly well I
noticed that as I got farther into the
game Walker's comments became more
vulgar and angrier
got the [__] heavy is [__]
down the executions are also getting a
lot more brutal where now instead of
punching them one or two times he's
either bashing in their skulls or
executing them with his pistol Walker is
really starting to go down the wrong
path here and is turning into a
psychotic killer although you could
argue that's already happened he's not
the only one who's gone off the deep end
though as the trio finally makes it to
the radio man Lugo ends up giving him a
piece of his mind and while he has been
a nice person up until this point even
angels can fall from Heaven
I was easier than I expected
thanks
mine are you really this
naive he kept the 33rd on our ass this
whole time he wasn't gonna let us just
walk out of here I did what was
necessary you don't get to make that
call well [__] you
just did that's enough we'll deal with
this later let's not kid ourselves here
did the radio man deserve it yeah which
is why I don't feel particularly bad
about his current fate but he
surrendered and was never going to kill
us as Adam said earlier in the level
it's three armed men versus a man with
an iPod their chances of dying to him
were slim plus since he was a part of
the 33rd he is yet again another person
we were supposed to rescue but ended up
killing the radio man now named Robert
Darden seemed to actually be an honest
to God journalist and he was but the
effects of Dubai had changed him like
everyone else and turned him into a
narcissistic radio man with a lack of
empathy in his words he wanted to be the
new Eddie Moreau given his current
circumstances Edward was a television
host and news reporter he was most well
known for his reporting during the
London Blitz in World War II which the
game references it seemed like his
appearances were met with positivity as
many people were able to keep up with
the day-to-day goings on in London and
it likely helped the people of London
feel like there was always someone to
turn to he would then use this Fame and
popularity to start a TV docu-series
called see it now which had a major
focus on dismantling McCarthy as and was
quite successful in doing so Edward was
also quite famous for his catchphrases
one of which I didn't even know was his
was the iconic good night and good luck
I always thought that was a Dying Light
thing either way given the situation
here in Dubai Robert saw the opportunity
to do something like that as he could
have jump started his career in radio
and journalism that's actually why he
came to Dubai in the first place as he
was stationed alongside Conrad and was
able to get first-hand information on
the crisis this allowed him to write
daily reports about what was going on
there while also giving him a chance to
uncover the real truth about that Dubai
cover-up we talked about earlier but
obviously none of his writings were
published as he went manic thanks to his
prolonged stay here in the Middle
Eastern desert
circling back to Walker's comment he
tells the people of Dubai that he's
going to rescue them but first they need
to deal with Conrad this leads to the
trio taking a helicopter and flying to
Conrad's position before a sandstorm
knocks them out what follows is a very
weird dreamlike sequence which has
Walker walking toward a giant burning
Tower while in here various characters
we've met throughout the game walk
toward us and condemn our actions Conrad
also comes by and says that 5 000 people
currently live in Dubai how many people
do you think are alive now it's meant to
get the player and Walker to think about
their actions but surprisingly here I
was agreeing with Walker again one thing
spec Ops the Line did really well at
least for me was its ability to get me
to side with Walker while also
disagreeing with him constantly I was on
board in the early chapters and agreed
that while things got tough we would
make it right once we win towards the
middle is where I started to break off
and thought that Walker was becoming
unhinged but somehow here I am back to
agreeing with him again and I think just
like Walker we both have this naive hope
that by the time we killed Conrad we
would win and be able to save the people
of Dubai and I was shocked not only the
fact that I was still sticking by a
walker but also how both our hopes and
dreams would be erased by the time the
game ended before we get there though we
have to go rescue the crew again as
Delta Force are all separated Adams was
overrun by the 33rd but we managed to
save him in time Lugo managed to make
his way to a refugee camp but the
chatter over the radio suggests that
something is going on and by the time
that we arrive we see that these
civilians had surrounded Lugo and hung
him Walker attempts to perform CPR but
it's too late lugo's gone and they've
killed him but it's here where we're
given another Choice the people won't
leave until we shoot so what do we do
while I love the white phosphorus scene
I think this might be the best part of
the game for me is it something I had a
choice in and everything that had
occurred in my head at this moment was
astonishing my first immediate reaction
was to shoot them they kill Lugo and he
was a friend it's probably why they made
him the comedic relief as well as the
one who dies because everyone likes
comedy people who make you laugh are
usually people you end up taking a
liking to but even without that he was
the one who was against the white
phosphorus attack it's another example
of good people dying while those that
terrorize and make a mess of the world
get to live on and I didn't want his
death to be just an their tally mark on
a clipboard Lugo out of all three
members of the squad didn't deserve this
so I wanted payback but I thought during
these brief few seconds about what I was
about to do was I really about to kill a
dozen or so people for Revenge that
didn't sit right with me so then maybe I
thought shooting a couple shots into the
first guy would work to let them know
that we're serious but then what's the
point I was ready to aim and shoot but
literally as my finger hit the trigger
in a split-second decision I stopped
go why you still can't
[__] animals get the [__] out of here
run faster I was seconds away from being
no better than Walker I had almost
crossed the line but as the achievement
said I held it
I had to reflect on that for a moment as
I was surprised that my first choice was
to fire into the crowd but what would
that solve yeah they're all guilty of
killing Lugo but can you blame them
we've made their lives a living hell
since we got here we have blown up city
blocks and killed hundreds of soldiers
who are not only American soldiers like
ourselves but we're also helping the
civilians survive as harsh as their
policies were and we also destroyed all
their water their lives while still not
great to begin with would have been
better had we not shown up so in my eyes
they have every right to hang us hell
I'd argue that's a merciful punishment
given what we just put them through this
conversation is also a good time to
bring up one of my favorite pieces of
Intel and that's a few loose bullets on
a table according to Walker silver was
something you would use to kill monsters
like how silver bullets were used to
kill werewolves while the refugees were
melting down silver to use his ammo thus
making the soldiers the monsters at the
time I thought this was a bit weird but
it makes a hell of a lot more sense now
as Walker and the player had become the
monster thanks their decisions here in
Dubai that being said though we've made
it this far so there's no point in
giving up now especially since lugo's
dead so Walker and Adams take the fight
to Conrad Walker is committed to killing
Conrad and putting an end to this and
while Adams agrees you can tell this is
all Weighing on him as he heavily
implies that both he and Walker deserve
the same fate as Conrad because of this
as the two reach an outpost they become
surrounded by a group of men and a
helicopter that says that if they don't
surrender they'll be shot Walker puts
his gun down but Adams wasn't having it
yeah I come this far to surrender the
only way inside that Tower the [__]
sake give it up
not well I'm still breathing fine and
keep breathing
run [__] Adams knew the mission
failed and was really just looking to go
out in a blaze of glory Walker wanted to
keep going because he was still focused
on the mission but Adams didn't care as
he knew that this thing had been over
for a while and also knew that the only
fate that he deserved was death so might
as well make it as glorious as possible
thanks to Adam's sacrifice though we
have finally come face to face with
Conrad we see a few men salute us and
then take an elevator to his quarters we
see him paint the scene of that mother
and child again saying that 47 innocent
people die thanks to Walker's orders and
someone has to pay for those crimes this
painting is odd though as Conrad should
know about this specific part of the
attack as he was never there but then it
starts making even less sense when we
discover that not only is Conrad dead
but judging from the body he's been dead
before we even arrived in Dubai meaning
every interaction with him wasn't real
times that reports of my survival have
been greatly exaggerated this is
impossible oh I assure you it is how not
how why you were never meant to come
here
we have our orders leave the city radio
command from outside the stormwalk they
send in the Cavalry we go home
[Music]
we're son of Michael
was it none of this would have happened
if you just stopped
[Music]
but on you marched
and for what
we tried to save you you're no savior
your talents lie elsewhere
[Music]
he turned us into [__] Killers this
isn't my fault it takes a strong man to
deny what's right in front of him and if
the truth is undeniable
true
what the hell happened I don't know he
just stopped moving Walker snap out of
it I get it we have to choose the truth
Walker is that you're here because you
wanted to feel like something you are
not
Hugo you left me to die I'm here because
you can't accept what you've done
broke you
colonel Colonel please
what's going on Walker it's Conrad he
did it all of it you needed someone to
blame so you cast it on me you're a dead
man
[Music]
no the truth is hard to hear walking but
it's time
you're all that's left
and we can't live this life forever
[Music]
with all of that laid out we are given a
choice shoot Conrad or shoot ourselves
before we get to that though what a
Twist that first part hit me like a
truck and was actually the deciding
factor regarding what ending I would
choose all this time I was talking about
me and Walker agreeing on saving all
these people despite how bad it's gotten
but both of us had completely forgotten
that that wasn't even our original
Mission All We were supposed to do was
assess the situation and radio outside
the storm wall but instead Walker
decided he wanted to play Hero and I
went along with him also speaking of
twists the game never points this out
but at the beginning of chapter 9
there's a memorial wall of all the Rogue
33rd members this not only shows how
much Conrad cared for those men even if
they went against him but on the wall
are the names of Lugo and Adams yet at
this point in the game neither of them
have died as for the rest of the scene
it's great but I do have one issue with
it though this twist doesn't really make
a whole lot of sense when in the context
of the prisoner decision if they were
both dead from the Star General Walker
did was look at two corpses why are
there snipers whose lasers are aimed at
two dead bodies why did they run away
when we made our choice why did they
shoot us for not complying if there was
never a choice to begin with and why is
Lugo and Adam's dialogue implying that
they see these two guys and believe it's
a real test Walker is the only one
hallucinating so it makes no sense for
them to be angry at Walker for killing
one of the prisoners when they've
already both been dead to begin with
furthermore Conrad told Walker that the
CIA was here to cover up what happened
in Dubai but Conrad is just a
hallucination so how to Walker come up
with that idea thirdly if the radio was
broken and nothing was coming out of it
why did all three of them move towards
the radio even though Walker was the
only one who could hear Conrad speaking
and finally if Conrad doesn't exist who
made the painting what I assume is going
on here is that Jaeger went for a more
emotional angle rather than a logical
one recently on the channel we talked
about Metal Gear and death straining and
both those games have a few moments
where logically nothing makes sense but
that's because it was sacrificed to
telling more emotional message logically
none of the aforementioned things make
sense but when looking at it what they
mean emotionally it fits a lot better
and I don't condemn for doing this I
never complained what a game sacrifices
Logic for emotion unless the plot is
wildly inaccurate because of it and I
don't plan on starting now as for Conrad
himself well a few Intel logs actually
foreshadow his current condition Colonel
Conrad was a decorated war vet but
during a tour in Afghanistan he failed
on one of his missions and that failure
haunted him for a while but thanks to
his previous efforts he was deemed a
hero so he thought that he deserved to
be one which is why he came to Dubai to
help but just like Walker he ended up
making it worse which is what led to
those 1300 people dying under his
leadership prior to his death he wrote a
letter to his wife and son then killed
himself after not being able to escape
the guild due to what happened here
overall it's a great twist it really
makes the player question what they're
even doing here and that's going to be
important to remember for our final
decision does Walker shoot himself or
shoot Conrad shooting Conrad means that
Conrad's the one at false and that
Walker was trying to help people killing
himself is well pretty self-explanatory
Walker realizes what he has done and
decides that for the first time he must
answer for his crime instead of putting
the blame on someone else earlier I said
that this is what helped me come to my
decision which is true but it was also
of all things a loading screen spec Ops
the Line like all games has a loading
screen but like Walker's dialogue it
changes the further in you progress it
starts with really simple things like
you can blind fire from cover or a
sandstorm has destroyed Dubai it'll even
occasionally throw in some
thought-provoking questions like if the
radio man answers to the 33rd then who
works for Conrad but then it gets really
dark like do you feel like a hero yet do
you even remember the mission and if you
were a better person you wouldn't be
here there are a ton of these tips and
it would be hard to catalog all of them
but they all follow the same idea it's
the game telling us to look at ourselves
and what we've become its wife
continuously mentioned the fact that the
allegiances of the soldiers are
confusing because the whole time we're
trying to figure out who the villain is
without even recognizing that it's been
you the whole time in this discussion
with myself is what gave me my answer if
I had to make one of these choices and
not go back and do the other ending for
Content I probably would have shot
myself shooting Conrad shows Walker
talking to one of the men from earlier
before realizing that they too didn't
even exist before calling for evacuation
and being shipped out of Dubai by some
U.S soldiers while this is a good ending
for Walker not only can you shoot these
soldrens out of surrendering allowing
you to get an even more Sinister ending
but more importantly does Walker deserve
that Walker and the player are one and
the same and realistically do either
deserve to walk out of here alive we
went against the mission and tried to
play Hero which led to us presumably
killing all of the 33rd Battalion
destroying 90 of Dubai killing 47 people
in a bombing and are about to kill the
rest of the city thanks to us destroying
the last bit of water left if I was
Walker I don't know if I could live with
myself after that and it's just like
what Adam said what do we deserve well
Adams knew and I Knew Too those more
spiritual than I could argue that Walker
could live on and repent in atone for
his sins which is a fair point but it
doesn't seem like he'll ever make a full
recovery given his Delirious date at the
end of the game plus how do you even
atone for this kind of thing this isn't
something like saying the wrong thing to
someone or stealing food we killed
hundreds if not thousands of people for
Nothing Even though Dubai was already in
Ruins by the time we arrived our
presence actually made it worse the more
we continued playing oddly enough the
team had actually planned on making a
far cry style ending in which the player
could leave Dubai after assessing the
situation allowing them to get the true
good ending but they didn't add it to
the game as it conflicted with the
message regardless I don't know if I
could forgive myself if I was in
Walker's shoes which is why I chose the
option I did as I said earlier though
the player can choose to shoot the
hallucination which caused him to walk
away while Conrad congratulates him for
being lucky enough to leave with his
life he's then picked up by some
soldiers who either escort him home if
you drop his gun or fired upon if you
decide to shoot if you kill all of them
a crazed Walker gets on the radio and
welcomes the new soldiers to Dubai if
you die the soldiers will shoot Walker
and as his life slowly Fades away he
reminisces about his time in Kabul with
Conrad in which they talk about going
home Conrad says that even if he wanted
to he can't go home as for soldiers like
him if they're lucky enough they do
what's not necessary and then they die
that's why all he wants is peace and as
depressing as it sounds Walker dying
here will finally given the peace he
wanted this ending is a really good
example of this game's impressive
attempt at portraying the villain spec
Ops the Line is a great game because
it's realistic the villain isn't some
evil Supernatural creature or a person
with zero morals it's just a human
Walker wanted to do the right thing Anew
in his heart that he wanted to save
these people but his circumstances and
choices ended up changing him further
reinforcing that anyone could be Walker
even if they have good intentions
there's a conversation like this wakan
read earlier where Walker sort of
apologizes by saying that he never meant
to hurt anyone to which Conrad replies
that no one ever does no one inherently
wants to hurt other people but sometimes
it happens and for Walker by the time he
noticed it was too late all this circles
back to the other piece of this game I
haven't mentioned and that's our choices
what changed because of them and did
they matter of course not if I didn't
nickel for how many games he talked
about on this channel that made me
rethink my life while also making my
choices pointless I'd have two and Soma
was the first one none of the choices we
made mattered all of it was just stuff
that mattered at the moment killing
Riggs or letting him burn was only there
to comment on the player's current
mindset same with the civilians that
killed Lugo the prisoners weren't even
real and saving or letting goal die
didn't matter is we got the info off his
corpse anyway the choices were pointless
but once again we shouldn't have even
been here to make these decisions in the
first place
spec Ops the Line is a fantastic game
with an incredible story and message
it's a game that makes the player out to
be the villain which doesn't happen
often usually there's some kind of loose
justification for these actions but spec
ops continually tries to undermine that
justification by showing you how much
destruction you've caused despite all of
this though we do have to end the video
on a bit of a sad note while the game
was met with positive reviews everything
after release was disastrous critically
the game succeeded but commercially no
one cared about it as its sales were
quite low which seems to be a running
theme for this series as the line is not
a standalone title but rather the eighth
game in a series called spec Ops the
original games were released around the
late 90s and early 2000s but didn't seem
to gather much press either as the
series went into hibernation for over a
decade before the line was released but
thanks to its failure to Garner
audiences there's a good chance we won't
ever get a sequel speaking of Jaeger Day
2 sadly haven't got much success either
as their first game Jaeger back in 2003
was met with mixed reviews and mediocre
sales in the other two games they made
after spec ops called Dreadnought and
the cycle Frontier also seem to have
suffered the same fate Jaeger can't
catch a break it seems but I do hope the
team knows that at the very least they
struck gold here with the line
they may not have sold well but most
people that played the game including me
know how impressive this product was
even if many people didn't buy it
originally despite its sad aftermath I'm
actually thankful I was able to play
this game as it's games like this that
I've recently come to appreciate a lot
more many games nowadays are long-winded
experiences created with the sole
intention of keeping you playing as long
as possible but I found that a short and
sweet experience can do the same thing
with greater success two games I love
dearly and will never shut up about are
fire watch and what remains of Edith
Finch these games are incredibly short
taking no longer than four hours to beat
and yet despite only playing them once
three years ago I can vividly remember
most of their events due to how
impactful they were while it's only been
a couple of weeks since I've played I'm
sure spec ops line will be one of those
games too I'm not sure when I'll play
this game again it could be weeks months
years or hell this might be the last
time I play it but none of that matters
as the story in the events that took
place here are never going to leave my
mind and that is something I feel is
often overlooked you don't need to play
a game multiple times Wrecking in over
hundreds or thousands of hours for it to
be memorable sometimes all it takes is
one one incredibly impactful and
Unforgettable experience
thanks for watching
thank you for watching today and I hope
you enjoyed bit of a short one today at
least compared to the fact that my last
analysis video was six hours long but
spec ops was a short game so it was
going to be a short video I'm not sure
what the next video will be is I have a
couple of projects I've been working on
in the background and I should probably
finish those up but if you turn on
notifications for the channel you'll be
able to know when video start production
as well as how close they are to being
finished it's something I've been doing
recently and a lot of you seem to enjoy
it so I'll keep posting more updates
regardless like the video if you enjoy
and subscribe if you're new think of my
returning viewers for coming back to
another video and take care everyone
goodbye